from a launch site in iran's central
desert a successful liftoff for a rocket
that tehran describes as its most
powerful yet
state television which broadcast the
launch reported that
yana reached a height of 500 kilometers
it said the three-stage rocket can carry
a satellite
weighing 220 kilograms or up to 10
smaller ones
iran often coordinates such tests with
national holidays this month it'll
celebrate the 42nd anniversary of the
islamic revolution
but the launch may also be a show of
strength ahead of potential negotiations
on a nuclear deal
i think that could very well be the
intended uh
timing for tehran to show the united
states that it's
its work continues on uh on missiles
just as the nuclear issue
uh continues to be you know increasing
crisis
the launch comes less than a year after
tehran put its first military satellite
into orbit
that stoke tension with the u.s which
has warned that tehran is using its
space program as a cover for missile
development
well good afternoon everyone u.s
president joe biden wants a return to
the 2015 nuclear deal
abandoned by donald trump which saw iran
restrict its nuclear program in return
for sanctions relief
the u.s secretary of state is warning
they don't have much time for
negotiations
it's a problem that could get more acute
because if iran continues to lift
some of these restraints imposed by the
agreement that could get down to a
matter of weeks
the bottom line is they are getting
closer to the point where they would be
either a threshold nuclear power
um or actually a nuclear power
tehran says the zulliana will carry out
scientific research
its launch is a reminder to the new u.s
administration that despite economic and
diplomatic isolation
iran is one of only a dozen countries in
the world with its own rocket technology
capable of putting satellites into space
victoria gatenby al jazeera